everyone's got a favorite as seen on TV
product with goodies like the Snuggie
shake weight and even Magic Mesh there's
no shortage of weird crap for Americans
to buy to solve problems we never knew
we had but for each home run there's a
horrible strikeout that should have
never been created let alone be
advertised on the airwaves we've seen
some weird as seen on tv products before
but you're going to need a whole lot of
OxiClean to purify your memories of
these horrible inventions bulb right do
you have trouble distinguishing whether
your toilet seat is up or down and do
you wish your nighttime trips to the
toilet could be accompanied by a ghostly
green or red glowing lights consider
this your lucky day because bull bright
has a solution for both problems simply
install the batteries and LEDs on your
toilet lid and start enjoying a
Christmas themed evacuation of your
bowels and bladder red means the seats
up green means it's down and if you
actually spend money on this it means
you're a lunatic dumped meals from the
maker of dump cakes now comes dump meals
because if there's one word in the vast
expanses of the English language the
denotes a delicious delicacy it's the
word dump dump meal sounds so appetizing
it's a wonder that more restaurants
don't feature them well make it's a
copyright issue they might have to come
up with a closely related knockoff like
splatter platters or tainted bowls the
possibilities are endless really sauna
pants any professional trainer worth
listening to will tell you that the key
to achieving fitness goals is a humid
crotch calories consumed versus calories
burned
forget all that because with sauna pants
you can strap what is essentially an
electric heating blanket to your groin
and just watch the pounds melt away and
possibly your chances of ever having
children but do you even know how hard
it is to make it to the gym and you have
kids neck magic air cushion if someone
told you they were going to strap a
device around your neck and use a pump
to slowly increase the pressure and pull
your head away from your shoulders you'd
probably wonder why your stalker was
being so detailed and upfront about his
plans but you can rest easy if he's
strapping the neck magic air cushion
around your throat because if he stops
just short blocking your airway you'll
experience soothing mussed
relaxation and even headache relief
trust us on this one
there are many commercials floating
around the neck magic air cushion but we
found one of what is essentially the
same product with an even better name
dr. Ho's neck comforter my secret hair
enhancer there's really no secret here
this is spray paint for your bald spots
nothing more nothing less
it's an aerosol can full of hair colored
paint that you can use to coat the bare
spots of your scalp in between clumps of
your thinning hair spray paints for
graffiti and patio furniture not human
heads
don't use the my secret hair enhancer
unless you're prepared for everyone to
know your secret right away that you
spray paint your bald head let this
commercial for my secret hair enhancers
predecessor from the 90s GLH great
looking hair say it all but the babes
are back potty putter like bulb right
potty putter attempts to tackle yet
another one of the many issues that
failed inventors field need to be
addressed spending too much time on the
toilet we always thought number two was
a fairly simple transaction but
apparently some people feel that
straddling the porcelain throne is just
too much waste of time now you can
practice your golf putt well you poop
which will hopefully improve your skills
and if your toilet overflows messes up
your bathroom putt and green
no problem just consider it a water
hazard or dump kitty litter on the mess
and you can practice getting out of a
sand trap better yet if you need more
practice go ahead and drag a toilet out
onto the actual golf course country club
will have no problem with that
euro club okay somebody needs to explain
what the deal is with golfers and going
to the bathroom the euro club is sadly
exactly what it sounds like a hollow
golf club that you pee into while a
green towel discreetly covers your
private parts it's a classy way to
relieve yourself on the course that
allows for minimal interruption of game
play besides how are you supposed to
make awkward eye contact with your
buddies if you're way off behind a tree
or bush that just wouldn't do it all
just a fair warning this is an easy way
to make your golf caddy get P owed poo
trap ever
one knows how challenging it is to bend
down and pick up a doggy doo-doo in an
attempt to alleviate this brutal task
here's a complicated harness system that
you can attach to an excited wiggling
dog as he practically drags his owner
out the door all to hang it back from
the dog's butt which the owner still has
to bend down and pick up so either wait
to buy this product until food trap
version 2.0 possibly improves the design
with a pulley system or you know just
bend down and pick up your dog's crap
easy butter it always stinks to try to
cut into butter and encounter all of the
problems that arise bent knives broken
fingers uneven chunks and divorce are
just a few so thankfully there is a
contraption that takes care of all of
that easy butter slices your butter into
perfect portions every time and even
shoots them out with a fun click it even
works on margarine it's like a staple
gun for the kitchen only dumber and
completely useless in every possible way
brush buddies One Direction singing
toothbrush because dental hygiene should
always come with an ear worm capable of
inspiring suicide there's now a
toothbrush that can play one direction
music with the push of a button on top
of being highly entertaining while
removing plaque this product offers the
added bonus of infuriating everyone else
whenever you brush your teeth just think
of the minutes of fun you'll have
fighting gingivitis while your wife
scales and silently consider smothering
you with a pillow tonight and the
children won't be left out either as
they'll undoubtedly be googling how to
legally emancipate themselves from you
it's fun for the whole family thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know what dumb products we
should put on our next list